I am the political animals who I think
Brits were lazy of ultros
instead of vote in the book for each
other and I've noticed a very reduced
part lost one time and there's a sign up
saying that 40% of violent criminals in
which we'd never seen queuing up the
polling stations before but because they
want to stop me we had 50 people that
were registered in one particular house
that were voting and so I lost my state
and I lost it by four and a half
thousand there was a tiny bit of a Lib
Dem
but the British Cameron told me I
couldn't discuss immigration I'm next
door in Halifax nice guy under Philip
lost his seat the second time because
again registering 52 a house and we
asked the Conservative Party to report
this to the police to investigate some
of the doggie practices and one funny
story in Bradford the Conservatives
which is in McAlester
and there were two Muslim candidate
suppressed and they were given a letter
of authority they were voting and then
losing their letter and then one of them
opened the window in the toilet no
climbing through the soil coming in
voting for a second and third time and
who's that Evans at understand party
making care to be in good business and
it all depends the Dutch people they
don't like it they can hear form I know
the telling the indigenous groups
leave the opposition and empowers it we
love you okay well thank you Dennis
believe it